there's a 16 year old girl right now
who's watching Gary me
she's smartest [ __ ] this is her parents
were in the industry and she wants to do
that she and she's not going to sell for
eight times
Avada earned out over 40 like its net
I've already done it
you ain't gotta be up in the office you
rat trap it will be too costly talked
about ownership and leverage 1800
sectors that out for average you'll
content out your ass as a human as a
human for you to be successful in how we
see the world you don't even need the
place you can literally [ __ ] start
over and you'd win that's why I'm the
Antichrist of you right because you
probably put up billboards well I mean
if they were $10 I put them up one night
right I would put up a thousand doors if
they were free to me it's not about
anything's dead to me it's what's the
price three I'll [ __ ] stand on a
mountain do smoke signals I'd be coming
in here really nice to meet you a
pleasure do you wear those kind of pants
every day is that a thing more every day
for 27 years the exact same outfit a
shirt clean white or just clean rain
white sometimes with paint I put on
clean shirt usually probably worst a
huge mystery with our hands yeah yeah
that was cool how are you good to see
you you see oh yes yes I know right how
are you that was amazing
please guys can stand well
[Music]
oh man it's good to see you again
yeah thank yourself what about this what
about your poor Gary I agree I'm trying
to live to a thousand I feel like I'm
going to end up being yellow one day
true or do not restraining up yeah like
we crushed that right I was smiling the
whole time we were doing I'm like this
dude has no idea how good he's getting
it like really don't go in that no it's
not that bad AJ they taught me to read
play straight pattern long to be the
people in the middle of like the
businesses and the kids like when you
think about the trade that you made with
Matt it's such a win for both parties
and that's fun in business like when
both parties win at such an extreme
level the fact that we're going to be
able to disproportionately impact small
and medium sized businesses right and
when I say medium sized businesses
people doing 100 200 300 400 500 million
in revenue and we're going to be able to
make kids who are not Peyton Manning
right and you know and Joe Montana you
know hundreds of thousands of dollars
off the field they would have never made
in every single other agency combined
that's cool the office can't be in there
exactly
[Music]
it's brand it's all the [ __ ] I wanna do
that's why I'm taking this mean there's
a [ __ ] stupid meeting for me on paper
if I'm averaging my time but not for
branding and opportunity and serendipity
like you know the way the world actually
works if the world actually worked on
math it would have been over by now
right
if it works on math then people would
have ran the algorithms and everything
would be set right just not real life
there in place
did you successor didn't success a thank
you do give it to me only because we're
building this whole thing for ourselves
like the whole conglomerate is being
built because I want to buy businesses
told journey is about building this
machine and then buying the biggest
businesses in the world so I think we're
so unique because our interests are
aligning in a way that is very powerful
because we're trying to figure it out
for ourselves India so work here
remind you they killed Kenny
we only have three opposite once you
have two human beings you have you think
we don't have characters well that's
right because I'm not a human being but
damn well thank you don't I say it thank
you
I'm going to tell you bad whenever I
come around I feel like a football
you've the good work thank you know if
it's a mentor you're your mentor someone
trying you know because you're good
you're very good at what you do I
appreciate it very good jesus [ __ ]
christ this kind of flash Jesus you're
available it's October 24th and 25th
doing a wine dinner there would be
amazing okay
because it's not as saturated as like
yes correct all auto send me Tyler and
Kim an email or did love you have
multiple runs great
are you sure to see me mark
[Music]
Marc Ecko wouldn't let you film we said
yeah you look sad brown like things like
this like midday like this way like I
would have been fine like catching you
like ad Avenu or two away every [ __ ]
minute man like you know I mean that
am i in a hurry yeah don't [ __ ] up my
[ __ ] hopping up before she goes to a
crash like aeroponic man eager children
a solution
thank you guys can see for this school
book women and time I am trying to give
me doing what's in a Catholic no one for
instance bhajami like the leader brother
Cooper that lean on like a little
fuchsia they said shuttle compromise at
my own feet so [ __ ] focused Iraq oh
whoa good turn I was exaggerating on
purpose yes
look snapchat effect blowing up don't
matter the crisis television my dreams
I'm confront in my life 22 and I'm
talented I do not like it like three
years if he was to start today on every
single thing he did exactly the same way
what would you want your best guess that
if you did everything exactly the same
way with it it was he quadruple where
would you where would you be right now
if I if I started today if you started
today and you actually did for three
years you and your girls account would
combine to be what instead of four
million your best guess three hundred
thousand four hundred thousand ah this
is and and I love that I had no idea
what you're going to say but I love that
I would say we're in the same range
people don't understand what moving
quickly in attention land ships mean you
can be best and that's great but there's
just such a disproportionate amount of
upside when you hit something right and
to our point from earlier about organic
reach by platform when I hopped on the
platform trust me with not thirty five
to fifty percent was closer closer to
100 so the the eyeballs were there in
the beginning and as I will decrease the
potential for gaining a following
organically on its own is very difficult
that's why we use influencers to be able
to reach new markets that we can draw
off to or rim ray and they were coming
at that organic reach variable and then
answer game environment does it go to
one to two percent like Facebook maybe
maybe going on or hopefully so
it just depends on how much Facebook
stock you all you're welcome
hey guys how are you good I like your
sneakers by the way ah great so thanks
for being here how's they going so far I
think everybody the world's gonna do X
is about jobs a job my preference is the
vlog if you've got it in you and by the
way it's pretty douchey to walk around
with a human being filming you and I'm
willing to be douchey more than anybody
so you got to get over that hurdle first
and that's a hurdle but if you can do it
there's nothing close because then
you've unlimited [ __ ] content alright
I have to go question Eric how are you
very good good it's a real finally meet
you after all this time I'm so excited
right now yeah your Punk that xx been
great crush it that's what we have and
you only 14 cents for using that Bank oh
yeah howdy how do I do you know you're
the little context for this and
obviously we share a lot of friends like
we're I'm so motivated to help and then
Dan break and try and I think nobody you
know I think you've always notice
nobody's going to intuitively understand
it better than this organization that's
impossible
yeah so I think like I'm just excited I
know no matter the righteous vision
monetary-ism conference in my life 22
another Ellington I do not like a vices
appetite quanity
champagne or anything I get it solely
when I know there's a new frontier right
I'll actually give me my briefings like
this thing you / breezy
get ready here from Gary decreases
five electro stop to me the land grab of
intuitive consumer behavior in my life
and that's why I will only jet
I already know I [ __ ] the whole agency
world that's all I really wanted to do
not because I'm not because not because
because I'm going to take all their
money I'll never get around to it it's
because I've now shown people the path
there's no sixteenth that's right
there's a sixteen-year-old girl right
now who's watching Gary Vee she's
smartest [ __ ] this is her parents were
in the industry and she wants to do that
she and she's not going to sell for
eight times the Buddha earned out over
four like it's net I've already done it
in entrepreneur never easier it's their
realization to meet you I really
appreciate time yeah I can we can I get
all your and forgetting some yourself
yeah yeah to do that well I'll make it
happen
thank you in a world of unlimited
vacation policy unlimited like like I
want to have all these macro
conversations because this is what I'm
thinking about of course it makes sense
of course man like like there's so much
like unlimited vacation policy has
empowered this company to do good more
than any company in this market that
alone I've accomplished everything one
show
get away my dog I can 100% we were sent
here that's just so I need to know the
diagram of Fame or that scratching that
edge of notoriety or like you know that
little start money money uh legacy and
and not the book like like like I would
be reading material yeah I'm yep you're
talking to guys very weird about this
one like most imperative ones we're cool
so then then you then they have to match
so if you care about legacy if they
leave a lot of money on the table I need
to know what the minimum number is so
that I can navigate that inconsistency
in your story and or the map of what we
should do I won't give into spasm makes
their official 106 in stock baby I love
you my location target boy yeah hey
focus the sky pausing care to me this
we looked there she said come here
should I just start tagging super left -
instead of you I'm fine with it do you
like it it's fine like what I do you
like getting the followers teddy me
being late hooked you guys up proper now
you get to be on now you get to watch
the askgaryvee show
alright I'll see a little bit do you you
know it's funny I got to tell you I'm
getting to know you more and more you
know what I like about you and I what I
really like about entrepreneurship a
little bit and I'm hoping it continues
to build momentum which is why I'm
bringing it up right now
I like that people love it so much
they want to give back to the game one
thing I've always noticed from you is
you always want to put on the Young's
like we see ourselves right it's cool I
love it I love it too are you're really
good at it enough that these open-closed
savvy freaks painted those marbles
the wrongs done when I do some sort of
thing on set next I will invite you in
your duet done
[Music]
[Music]
Roxas asked me for selfie videos to
close out the episode follows a car I
said no
[Music]
you